It seems like half of the comments think this
movie is an Abe Sapien origin story from the
Hellboy universe and the other half think
we're dealing with the Creature from the Black
Lagoon.
Throughout this video, I'll be presenting
the evidence for both these theories, so stay
to the end, where I'll give you my answer
on what this film actually is.
Early on, we've got some surreal imagery of
furniture floating in an underwater room,
but if you look closely you'll see that it's
not just the room that's underwater, but there
some fish swimming by outside that window
as well.
My prediction is that these shots are part
of a dream sequence because generally in my
experience, desk lamps don't work underwater,
they just end up electrocuting the victim.
I mean... uh... forget I said that.
But even if lamps did work underwater, they'd
probably have to be plugged in.
In the corner of the frame here, you see what
appears to be a tentacle, something we've
seen plenty of in the Hellboy movies, whereas
Creature from the Black lagoon is much more
grounded in reality.
Side note: I love how they put their Fox Searchlight
logo underwater, it reminds me of the 30th
Century Fox thing they used in Futurama.
Her waking up here supports my theory that
the shots in the beginning of the trailer
are part of a dream, and she's also in the
same room as that underwater part, so I'm
pretty sure this scene represents her waking
up into the harsh reality of her real world
responsibilities.
Also, time seems to be a major theme in this
movie.
You'll see over and over and over in this
trailer that the tracking of time seems to
be important.
This could be due to the fact that fish people
in fiction tend to live much longer than humans,
which is a weird consistency when you think
about it considering how short lifespans tend
to be for actual fish.
One example of a fictional fish-person with
an extended lifespan, you guessed it: Abe
Sapien from Hellboy.
The Hellboy movies seem to take place in the
year they were released, as suggested by a
reference to the recent advent of YouTube
in the second film.
"They put them up on YouTube.
God, I hate YouTube."
Abe is stated to have been discovered alive
in 1865.
That makes him at least 139 years old during
the first Hellboy movie.
So perhaps the constant references to time
in the trailer play into the theme that the
protagonist, Elisa, really has a limited time
with this fish-person, whatever he may turn
out to be, in the grand scheme of things.
I've seen romantic complications caused by
a difference in the speed of aging in other
stories before, so I wouldn't be surprised
if that was a big part of The Shape of Water
as well.
I guess only time will tell.
Haha, oh I am just not funny.
According to the internet, the movie takes
place in 1963 and has some connections to
the Cold War, however, I think this part of
the film must start a bit earlier in 1962,
and maybe it carries over into '63, because
this date, September 18th, falls on a Wednesday
in '63, but a Tuesday in '62.
I looked up the date in 1962 and apparently
some nuclear testing was performed by the
USSR that day.
In an interview earlier this year, Doug Jones,
who by the way is the same actor who played
Abe Sapien in Del Toro's Hellboy films, said
the following about his role in The Shape
of Water:
"I'm being studied and tested in a U.S. government
facility in 1963, so the Russian Cold War
is on, the race for space is on, so there's
all that backdrop and that undercurrent.
I'm being tested for how can they use me for
advantages in military or space travel, or
my technology-can we make this usable for
humans?
So they're trying to keep me a secret from
the Russians."
So that leads me to believe that the The Shape
of Water is about the US is developing this
supernatural research program to as a reaction,
to try to outpace the USSR in the Cold War.
Whether or not that turns out to be the Bureau
for Paranormal Research and Defense, Section
51, from the Hellboy franchise, remains to
be seen.
Moving on, this wallpaper, reminds me a lot
of the carpet in Room 237 in The Shining.
That's probably just a coincidence, or at
most an homage, but it did get my attention
enough to take a closer look at it and notice
that it also looks kind of like fish scales.
It's shown again at the end of the trailer
and it really starts to look fishy.
There's something special about these shoes
that they keep showing.
I'm not entirely sure what it is yet, but
go ahead and leave your ideas in the comments,
and if I do a follow-up video, I'll put your
comment up on the screen.
She cleans these shoes with an oddly specific
duck brush thing.
And overall she seems to be obsessed with
cleaning, because in addition to keeping her
own things things, she also does it for a
living.
Webbed fingers.
That could support the idea of either Hellboy
or Black Lagoon, but again, I'd have to lean
more towards Hellboy.
The hand looks more humanoid than the hands
of the Creature, which are much wider and
more claw like.
That's not to say that if this was related
to Creature of the Black Lagoon that Del Toro
wouldn't have updated the design a bit.
It has been over 60 years since the movie
came out, and to be fair it's also been 9
years since the last time Abe Sapien showed
up on screen, so it's possible we'd see a
fresh look there as well.
In this shot, a warning on the wall reads
"NO LONE ZONE", which I guess means that no
one should ever be in there unsupervised.
Kind of like she is right here.
Also, if you don't know what these are, it's
a security measure meant to reinforce that
"no lone zone" rule.
The door only opens if both buttons are pressed
at the same time, so you need two people to
do it.
If you are a Hellboy fan, you probably didn't
miss this one: eggs!
Abe Sapien loves eggs, so that's a huge connection.
However, you'll notice that the eyes...
wait a minute... where have I seen this before?
But anyway, you'll notice the eyes are not
quite the same as Abe's, but do keep in mind
that he can change the appearance of his eyes
using those contacts that he wears, even though
you're not supposed to wear your contacts
underwater.
Also, the creatures in that franchise do change
their appearance with age just like anyone
else.
This chain gives the impression that this
creature might be dangerous, which would be
a tally for Black Lagoon.
Abe Sapien is not much of combatant.
He only get into one scrum during the series,
which he runs away from.
The Creature from the Black Lagoon is confrontational,
has the power to rock the boat, literally,
and breaks out of a cage with thick wooden
bars.
Also, this guy's hand is wrapped up, so it's
likely that he was attacked by said creature.
The obvious rebuttal is that if this creature
is so dangerous, why is it going and falling
in love with Amelie...
I mean, Elisa.
Well, Doug Jones says that this creature is
the last of it's kind.
That doesn't mean it was always that way.
So maybe this isn't the same creature from
the black lagoon, but a descendant.
If the descendant was brought up under different
conditions, maybe it's less hostile.
And let's not forgot that in The Creature
From The Black Lagoon, all of the men who
are caught off guard get killed, but Kay,
the one female of the group, leaves herself
vulnerable, but the creature just touches
her legs, and then at the end, (spoiler alert
for Creature from the Black Lagoon) kidnaps
her but does not kill her.
Maybe Lagoon Creatures need love too.
Back to the trailer, this scientist guy claims
that the creature is intelligent, capable
of language and understanding emotions.
Both Abe and the Creature are intelligent.
Abe reads four books a day and is able to
extract information from people he meets.
The Creature devises a plan to trap the boat
inside the lagoon using a huge tree branch.
Abe demonstrates the ability to use language,
which the creature does not.
That doesn't mean it's impossible, it just
doesn't happen during the movie.
I would argue that both are capable of understanding
emotion.
Abe falls in love during the second movie,
which leads to a glorious scene involving
two supernatural monsters singing a love song.
The Creature expresses both anger and love;
anger when he retaliates at them for shooting
at him and love, as I mentioned earlier, towards
Kay.
In the Shape of Water trailer, Elisa plays
some music for the fish-man.
She offers him up some jazz music, maybe that's
not his thing, they settle on classical music.
Or at least, something in the style of classical
music.
The artist of this track is actually Madeleine
Peyroux.
She was born in 1974, over a decade after
this movie is supposed to take place.
So that doesn't really make sense, it seems
Guillermo Del Toro is pulling a Baz Luhrmann
in this instance and using music from the
wrong era.
But the point is, that this track, which features
instrumentals you might hear in classical
music is what makes this creature dance, and
Abe Sapien is also a fan of such music.
If you are curious about the song itself,
it's called La Ja-vanaise, and the lyrics
translate roughly as follows:
"I admit I went through hell, didn’t you
my love?
Before I caught wind of you (met you) my love.
Whether it pleases you or not
In dancing the Javanaise,
We loved each other for the length of a song."
That last line could tie back into the time
thing I mentioned earlier; because he lives
much longer than her, it may feel like their
love was short lived to him.
We also know Abe is a sucker for poetry and
love songs, and this may be the origin of
why those things resonate with him.
Next thing.
"The natives of the Amazon worshipped him."
Well, the Black Lagoon is located in the Amazon.
Abe on the other hand was found in Washington,
but we don't know where was located before
that, or if the Amazonian natives worshipped
a different member of his species back in
the day, before he became the last remaining
member.
This seems to be the same room as Elisa's
apartment from the beginning of the trailer.
Over here we see a drawing board.
Later in the trailer, when we see this rendering,
we know that Elisa is most likely the artist.
There's also a self portrait of her peaking
around a corner, possibly foreshadowing the
fact that she'll be sneaking around later
in the movie.
Like in this next shot of the trailer.
Calling it now: I think this scene is part
of the dream too.
Outside the movie theater, if you look behind
the staircase, we can make out part of a word.
Being that it is a cinema, it probably says
"feature" or "featured".
But I was thinking, what if it says "creature",
or even "creature feature".
That could explain why the creature is the
only one interested in seeing this movie.
Perhaps there's a jealousy subplot where the
creature longs for someone of it's own kind.
By the way if you can figure out what movie
this is, let me know in the comments.
The bloody handprint here doesn't look like
a normal human hand, so I'm gonna guess that
is also the creature, meaning he probably
escaped and got himself into some trouble.
This guy is asleep, so he won't be much help
as a witness of this crime.
Based on this license plate, it looks like
the movie takes place in Maryland, possibly
Massachusetts.
If you're wondering where Hellboy is set,
it's in New Jersey.
And if you aren't familiar with American geography,
all of those locations are set in the Northeast
region, not too far away from one another.
While Black Lagoon was set in the Amazon,
much of that crew was American, so it would
make sense that they might capture something
and bring it back with them.
I don't know who's bath this is, but this
container on the side stuck out to me.
It's labeled: Aviex, a company that develops
vaccines to combat parasitic diseases.
Definitely a strange item to have laying around
the bathroom.
Now I could be wrong about this one, but I
think the voice at the beginning and end of
the trailer is Doug Jones.
Obviously that's significant because he played
Abe Sapien, but that doesn't confirm that
The Shape of Water is a hellboy spin-off,
because director Guillermo Del Toro likes
to work with the same actors over and over
again, just as many directors do as part of
their auteur, part of their directorial style.
The reason that it would be significant if
that was indeed his voice is; A) he talks;
and B) he refers to Elisa as the princess
without voice, and if you've seen Hellboy
II, you know he kind of has a thing for princesses.
I'm not saying that Elisa is literally a princess,
but he likes calling a girl princess, so that's
more evidence that these movies are connected.
So now you have a good argument for this movie
being connected to either the Hellboy or Creature
of the Black Lagoon franchises.
I think there is quite a bit more support
for the Abe Sapien idea, but I have seen an
article online that basically shoots down
the possibility, saying that fans are trying
too hard to connect the dots, much as many
of my commenters have said about these trailer
analysis videos.
The article also brings up that Del Toro legally
wouldn't be able to make such a film due to
a reboot of the franchise already being in
development.
But how to do we know that Del Toro isn't
involved in the reboot?
How do we know this movie isn't a part of
it?
Creature of the Black Lagoon is also being
remade in 2019, but nobody's arguing against
the possibility of that.
You have a fish person who likes eggs and
vintage music.
There's no proof that this one has telepathic
abilities, but he clearly has a connection
with a girl who is mute, she can't speak.
"When he looks at me, he does not know how
I am incomplete."
He's able to understand her despite the fact
that she can't talk.
In 2002, before any of the Hellboy stuff came
out, Del Toro was briefly attached to a remake
of Creature from the Black Lagoon, so I think
he's just a fan of it, he's inspired by it,
and that's why we see these similarities.
There was also an article recently where Mr.
Del Toro flat out denies the existence of
Hellboy III.
Does this mean that Shape of Water can't be
a Hellboy spin-off?
Not exactly.
I'm going to spoil the end of M Night Shyamalan's
Split right, so if you haven't seen that,
then skip ahead like 20 seconds, but I think
what GDT is doing here is creating doubt to
create surprise.
I remember shortly before Split came out,
Shyamalan responded to a tweet asking about
a sequel to Unbreakable.
He said that he had a script sitting on his
kitchen counter and created the expectation
that this might be something that happens
a few years down the road.
Then just a few months after that, we got
Split and it was a delightful surprise.
I see The Shape Of Water kind of playing out
the same way.
I don't think it will be heavy handed with
the Hellboy references, I think it will be
it's own movie that happens to work in this
universe.
Kind of like Split last year, kind of like
10 Cloverfield Lane.
So that's what I believe, I'm gonna put my
eggs in that basket.
Pun intended.
If you're looking forward to this movie too,
let me know by liking this video, and if you
love creepy movies, you're in the right place.
Go ahead and subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, yes, this is my video
this week, I'm gonna be going on vacation
for the rest of weekend so you'll see me again
on Sunday the 30th at 2PM pacific for the
first ever episode of The Deadstream.
If you haven't heard, I'll be joined by Lady
White Rabbit and Mortis Media for our first
ever streaming event.
You don't want to miss it, so ring that deathbell
for notifications and I will see you in The
Deadstream, assuming we both survive.